[Musique]
s'il continue km an je suis conseillère
municipale de canon je le connais c'est
vraiment rien strictement rien à la
politique
il ya beaucoup de choses qui me
scandalise est donc c'était une
obligation pour moi de m'engager pour
faire changer les choses à mon niveau
pour aller vite
un e candidat de la république le leur
on est tous différents avec des des
parcours des parcours différents mais
qu'on met tous des élus et des candidats
de l'aed public ça ça me semblait me
semblent importantes
on est les seuls par exemple avoir faire
un programme de 12 pages auraient table
notamment le contrôle des fonds publics
nous ne sommes pas contre 2 d'accorder
des fonds publics à des entreprises
permettent d'évoluer mais nous réclamons
le contrôle des fonds publics il faut
qu'elles nous disent qu'elles en font et
il faut qu'on comprend échangiez grève
si on en boit en bois de proximité même
sous la pluie en fait campagne
on est deux ballons et on a toujours été
dans la terreur le sera toujours
vous savez faire campagne c'est pas à se
montrer partout comme comme beaucoup ont
fait campagne en laiton me même